good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this monday morning you call it the two
ps parties and prices it's the start of
what could be a defining week for the
prime minister sue grey's report into
how lockdown rules were broken in
downing street is due to be published in
the next couple of days reports suggest
it will contain photographs of illegal
gatherings and it will trigger another
investigation by mps into whether boris
johnson misled parliament hanging over
it all is the question we'll be putting
to the chief secretary to the treasury
that's simon clark in just a few moments
what will the government do to protect
families from soaring inflation it's
monday the 23rd of may
the prime minister awaits the sue gray's
report into lockdown breaking parties in
downing street
fears of a global food crisis as boris
johnson and president zielinski discuss
russia's blockade of odessa stopping
exports from one of the world's biggest
grain producers
the uk is expected to announce more
cases of monkey pox this morning anyone
at risk of having caught the virus is
advised to isolate for 21 days
manchester city says sorry after aston
villa's goalkeeper was struck on the
back of the head by a supporter during a
pitch invasion they promised to ban the
fan for life
man city's remarkable comeback clinching
the premier league on a dramatic last
day of the season
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
right around the world a royal occasion
with a big platinum jubilee celebrations
just around the corner joined by the
royal commentator and editor that's
robert johnson
and green with envy will speak to
award-winning designer and landscape
architect that's joe perkins about his
garden of the future at the chelsea
flower show
[Music]
good morning everybody football violence
is back in the spotlight after one of
the most enthralling and dramatic title
races in years the manchester city
champions of england but their match
against aston villa will also be
remembered for a pitch invasion at full
time and an apparent assault on villa's
goalkeeper by a supporter let's find out
more becky is standing by in manchester
for us this morning hi becky tell us
more
well man city have said they sincerely
apologize to villa goalkeeper robin
olsen they've also said that they're
launching an investigation as are the fa
fa and there'll be an indefinite stadium
ban for this fan when they are found now
villa have said that olson is completely
fine but took a bang on the back of the
head they said yesterday they consider
the mata closed and they won't be
launching a complaint now thousands of
man city fans invaded the pitch after
the final whistle they had banners and
flares and it was a celebration but
there were ugly scenes they also sat on
top of a goal and broke a crossbar and
players had to be escorted off the pitch
to safety and it's the latest latest in
a series of pitch invasions at premier
league games raising questions about
player safety and it's a shame for the
fans and the club here that it has
overshadowed what was a remarkable
comeback for city they were two two nil
down to villa with 20 minutes to go and
managed to score three goals in five
minutes seeing off the challenge from
liverpool who won in their game against
wolves to be crowned champions of
england again you can hear some horns
honking there people here very happy it
was the fourth premier league trophy for
city in five seasons and they'll be
celebrating today with an open top bus
parade with the team through the city
kicking off at 6pm
thanks very much indeed becky pleased to
say the minister's with us nice simon
clark did you watch the footy yesterday
uh well i was watching the the actual
day highlights and uh what a what a
great story uh that is really i mean i
do feel for liverpool because uh
obviously they they put together the
most amazing season but uh
yeah i mean city are incredible and as
much as it pains me as a middlesbrough
supporter the gap between the top of the
top flight and the rest just keeps
growing wider yeah it does it does sorry
for burnley as well
very sorry for burning anyway that's a
different channel all together sorry
sorry uh so let's talk about cost of
living to study should we michael lewis
uh the boss of eon he's been talking
about it as you know he says 40 of
people could be in fuel poverty by
october george osborne says a windfall
tax is inevitable it is isn't it well we
continue to look at this situation very
very close i mean the first thing to say
is uh we've put together a package worth
22 billion pounds so far this year of
which nine billion is targeted directly
at
measures affecting energy and
uh we we recognize that there is a a
real challenge for households up and
down the country which will likely get
worse in the autumn when the
next round of the energy price cap uh
kicks in so yes we do we do we do want
to to make sure that we take the action
that we need what i would say is that we
want to make sure we get the action that
we take right on on the concept of a
windfall tax
itself
we are very very clear that there is a
real need at a time when the industry is
making very significant profits to see
those profits reinvested in new offshore
installations getting more out of the
north sea at a time which is obviously
vital in terms of energy supply but also
good for jobs and the wider economy if
we do not see that investment
materialized then we are very clear that
all options are on the table
sorry what would it not why would it
well ultimately that's a question for
the industry to answer i was saying they
still would aren't the bp the head of bp
said he still would even if there was a
windfall i was present at a uh summit
that the prime minister held at number
10 a few months ago with the industry
itself we were talking about the
incentives for uh the industry to get
get stuck in in the north sea and to
actually make sure that we get the
capacity that we need to wean us off a
reliance from russian oil and gas and
they were really clear this was a range
of companies small and large not just
the bps in this world but
a whole range of providers and they were
really clear that after such a difficult
few years during a pandemic when of
course their profits absolutely
nosedived that they needed a period
where they could have time to reinvest
if that doesn't happen
now that obviously they are making very
significant profits then all options uh
are on the table here because we've got
to make sure that we uh we support
families yeah uh jesse norman a former
financial secretary to the treasury i
mean he's been tweeting about that very
point and he said do those who oppose a
levy think oil and gas companies should
enjoy a one-way bet in which they
benefit from public support when prices
fall but make no extra contribution when
prices rise well i mean look jesse makes
a very powerful point there and you know
we are certainly not ruling it out i
mean what i would say is obviously i'm
not ever instinctively drawn to
uh to to to increasing taxes insofar as
it risks deterring investment in
new capacity and new jobs but look it is
it at least our extraordinary
circumstances we recognize there are
extraordinary pressures on family
finances and the industry needs to hear
the message loud and clear if investment
doesn't go in
we can't rule out
73 percent of those who voted
conservative in 2019 support a windfall
tax well i think the public uh are
absolutely concerned about the situation
that they can see and you're not there
from what you were we're not ruling it
out i mean as i say we're not we're not
at this point making any any
announcement but we are we are
definitively known
well look we have always said to the
industry this is something which was
communicated loud and clear back earlier
in the spring shortly after the russian
invasion that we need to see
uh the the industry step up to its part
of the bargain and invest in north sea
uh delivery because if that doesn't
happen then they are in effect just
banking the profits and not doing
anything uh to to justify those and and
these are
uh effectively as you say one off and uh
and
and extraordinary uh extraordinary gains
for the industry so the chance was very
clear we're not philosophically
attracted to this but if the situation
doesn't improve in terms of them
stepping up to the plate uh we can't
rule this out what do you mean by
stepping up to the plate
investing putting in the putting in
putting in these these extra profits to
actually make sure that they are setting
up new fields for offshore if they do do
that then you wouldn't be looking well i
think i think if we can see that the
industry is reinvesting these profits
into the next generation of nausea oil
and gas which is what we need as a
transition fuel both to help with uh
current supply problems but also
crucially to to transition the wider
economy to net zero surely
they can do both at the moment given the
amount of money that they're making well
we we obviously keep that situation
under review we would love to see as i
say these extra profits going into
something really productive and tangible
in the real economy that's what we'd
like the industry to do that's signal
that we have hoped to send to the
industry which they in fairness more or
less committed to when
they met the prime minister and the
business secretary and myself earlier in
the spring so
it is it is a test for the industry does
this does this investment come forward
and if it doesn't uh frankly reflecting
the seriousness of the situation uh they
can expect the government to have to
look at all our options let's talk about
the long-awaited sugray report
um i read in my morning papers that a
whitehall source is saying sue gray is
playing politics and enjoying the
limelight a little too much um a slur
ahead of her report being published
later this week you'd condemn that i'm
sure i i would i mean i think
the one thing i would say about sugra
and i've never met her but
i've heard a great deal about her is
that you know by repute she's one of the
most fiercely independent
and professional civil servants in in
the whole with in the whole of
government and brings a vast range of
experience to bear so i don't think
there's any politics there's obviously a
range of questions practical questions
involving doubtless uh discussion with
the police and the civil service
authorities about what
uh what what can go into this report and
when it should be uh published but in in
no way do i think is there is there
anything other than a practical
dimension to the question of when it
comes out now that the police have
concluded their investigation much made
of this meeting between the prime
minister and mrs grey regardless of who
called it i mean who we don't know uh
why on earth would the pm agree to go to
a meeting like this ahead of the report
being published well my understanding uh
is that the meeting was instigated by
doesn't matter that's great but but i
agree i don't think that's i i don't
well it matters only in so far as that
explains that he wasn't the one
instigating it there are as i said there
are lots of practical questions here
which need to be bottomed out in terms
of for example
who can be named uh in in in this report
and
the extent to which uh photographic
evidence can be included i think it is
it is important that those practical
dimensions are resolved do i think in
any way that the integrity of this
report should be questioned no because
as i say
sue gray has a reputation which dates
back decades in terms of her ability to
make judgments without fear or favor and
i think she will absolutely deliver it
even if it was mrs gray who called the
meeting and she categorically says that
wasn't the case um both sides saying it
wasn't them why would he attend a
meeting when why didn't he just say you
know what let's wait until this meet
until the report's been published and
then we can talk about it as i say it
would have been in essence to have
received an update and to why then
well on the basis if you were invited to
meet and as i said it it it is my
understanding that that was the basis so
he could have said no he's surprised i
mean ultimately ultimately he could have
done but look it's the point here is i
don't think it it would it would in any
way it would have been improper indeed
it would have been somewhat churlish i
think to have declined so you understand
that the optics are not good when a head
of an independent uh allegedly
independent report she's a civil servant
so how independent is it uh report being
published the prime minister has a
private meeting with the person that's
writing the report the civil service is
independent i think it's really
important we we reaffirmed that this
process is is totally independent of uh
any political uh pressure and what's her
boss
well her boss is so simon case the the
the cabinet
well ultimately the prime minister's in
charge of the government but the the the
civil service stands apart from the
political structures of government and
ms gray as we've discussed is one of the
uh the most
uh the most respected yeah
i i do not believe in any way
that uh we should we should conflate the
fact that the prime minister obviously
sets atop the whole of government from
the fact the civil service is capable of
standing apart from the political issues
of the day and indeed that's that's how
for example going back to 2010 coalition
negotiations were broken for example
there has to be an element whereby the
civil service and government stand apart
and they do absolutely
go back to my question which is the
optics you must accept are somewhat
askew by the prime minister i i i really
really don't think so as i say this is
there are lots of genuine practical
issues when publishing a report of this
nature which has
significance not just obviously for the
prime minister himself but crucially for
a whole number of people in downing
street many of whom of course do not
have a voice and a platform you know
very junior civil servants very junior
political staffers the question of
whether any of them are named in this
report the question of what uh evidence
as i say is included within it the
questions uh you know are not are not
straightforward here and are genuinely
sensitive for people's lives and careers
and
our public profile so i think i think it
is it is important to get involved with
that should you if it's an independent
well as i said i do not believe that
this meeting was anything other than a a
discussion of the technicalities of the
process and as i said i think it it it
would be genuinely
wrong uh to to impugn that there has
been any pressure put on the on the
nature of this report in any way and i
believe that when it's published we will
see that this is we will you say the
report could be significant for the
prime minister in what way well
ultimately this is a report which is
hotly anticipated the fact we're talking
about it now shows the profile which
it's uh attracted over recently could it
put his position in jeopardy i mean also
ultimately uh my faith in the prime
minister is is absolute uh we we've
heard from the police last week that
they've concluded their investigations
and the the the prime minister received
a fine for which he is rightly and i i
know sincerely apologized that was for
one incident of a uh of a slice of
birthday cake between me i understand
but he's overseeing he's overseen a
regime where 126 people 126 fines have
been issued and and he has taken full
responsibility
about the events in in downing street
and obviously he's set in train a series
of reforms to make sure that
that building is is running the most
professional possible fashion
going forward but i think we also need
to to remember without excusing what
happened but by way of context the
extraordinary pressure that that group
of people were under during the the
course of the pandemic and and the fact
that they were not uh you know they were
working the longest imaginable hours
under the most enormous amount of
pressure that in no way diminishes the
seriousness of what happened but it does
provide some context
let me just um ask you before i let you
go um 20 monkey pox cases in the uk so
far more to be we're expecting will be
told about later on today how worried is
the government
well as with any uh new disease and
obviously after the cover pandemic
doubly so we we continue to monitor this
very very closely i i think i would say
i'm cautious but i'm certainly not
concerned in the sense of sort of uh
feeling any uh any concern about our
ability to handle this situation
crucially there is a vaccine which is
available which works for monkey parks
and
all the evidence is is that it's spread
by physical contact so it's not an error
physical contact exactly and that being
the case the the risk of community
transmission is much lower as i said we
have a working vaccine if people present
with symptoms or they have very close
contacts then we are advising that they
quarantine for three weeks but the
threshold for that is is quite high it
really does need to become physical
contact or sexual contact and we're
hearing about a baby in in icu aren't we
uh well i i'm not aware of that case i
mean certainly uh you know we we do urge
particular caution with immunosuppressed
with pregnant women all the groups who
are normally more vulnerable uh and yeah
what i would say is we we're we're
cautious but we're certainly not uh in a
position where i would in any way worry
the public that this is uh some some
repeat of cover because it certainly
does not appear to be an anywhere near
the same uh platform of seriousness we
must let you go minister thank you very
much thank you for taking the time to
join us thanks very much looking at the
front pages of the newspapers this
morning for you let's start with the
daily telegraph claiming that the
cabinet secretary will come under heavy
pressure to resign as the sugray report
is expected to conclude that he bears
ultimate responsibility
daily mail says that allies of the pm
are claiming it was sue gray who
requested the meeting with him ahead of
her report into partygate
the eye says the uk government will hold
off on helping people deal with rising
prices as boris johnson focuses on
partygate the metro reports the rise in
the cost of living is leading to people
shoplifting food to feed themselves and
their families
express says campaign groups are warning
the health of millions at risk this
winter because of the rise in bills
and the daily marriage reporting the
head of the energy company eon has
called on the pm to prevent more people
falling into fuel poverty
still to come on the program for you
this morning pressure on the pm we'll
speak to the former justice secretary
and formatory mp david gork about what
we should be looking for from sugray's
report into downing street parties
we'll speak to the global health expert
about the spread of monkey pox with
officials expecting a significant rise
in infection in infections this week
and as russia steps up its assault on
eastern ukraine we'll speak to the
former chief of the general staff lord
richard dallet
prime minister has written a letter to
the children of ukraine telling them
they are not alone he also spoke with
ukraine's president zielenski on sunday
about the blockade of odessa the
country's biggest port that's making it
harder to aid in and exports out and
because ukraine is one of the world's
biggest grain producers that's also one
of the factors driving higher food
prices everywhere well our international
affairs editor dominic wagon is in
odessa for us this morning um hello to
dominic so tell us what's happening
there in odessa this morning good
morning
well not much okay the the grain
elevators stand idle the ships are
moored up with nowhere to go because
russia has a blockade out to sea on the
black sea and ukrainians have mined the
seas to protect themselves from russian
attacks and the problem with that is is
is beginning to register i think with
world leaders like boris johnson there
is a massive food supply crisis looming
they call ukraine the bread basket of
europe it's effectively the bread basket
for the world because 400 million people
around the world depend on the grains
supplied by ukraine and the reason for
that is has incredibly fertile rich
black earth that allows it to export 70
percent of its grain now normally that
goes through nearly all of it goes
through the port behind me and the ports
along the the black sea and that can't
get out which means at the moment there
are 25 million tons of grain trapped in
silos here but also in farms across the
country and then another 25 million
needs to come off the fields in the
harvest in july and if that can't get
out of here then it's going to lead to
starvation for 1 in 20 people
effectively 400 million people is 120th
of of the world's population is going to
lead to social unrest and it will lead
to rising food prices uh for for us in
the west as well and there isn't a clear
solution to this lifting the blockade is
going to be very difficult uh ukraine
says that the west has to come up with
the political courage to send in naval
ships to escort those grain ships out of
here or supply the weapons to let them
defend their sea lanes themselves
and getting the land borders open isn't
really a solution because it will allow
around two million tons of grain to get
out of the country and it needs to be
five or seven million tons so it's a
problem that i think is just beginning
to concern world leaders they're trying
to work out what to do about it if they
can't find a solution and there isn't
really a very easy solution to see it is
going to lead to rising food prices
social unrest and for some people
potentially millions of people
starvation
okay thank you thanks a lot john
also making news for you this morning
the uk is expected to announce more
monkey pox cases today as it takes steps
to contain the outbreak new guidance
says people who have been in close
contact with someone who has the virus
should self-isolate for up to three
weeks symptoms include fever headaches
and skin rashes we just heard from a
government minister who said he was
cautious but not concerned about the
uk's ability to handle the situation
people in scotland are heading out to
work this morning with a new railway
timetable that has 700 fewer services a
day on many routes the last trains will
now depart before 8pm the scottish
government which runs the railway says
it's because they don't have enough
drivers
business leaders are meeting in davos
for the first in-person world economic
forum since the pandemic the war in
ukraine is set to be top of the agenda
with a video address by ukrainian
president zielinski this morning
oxfam is calling on governments around
the world to take urgent action to
tackle rising inequality figures from
the charity show a new billionaire was
created every 30 hours during the
pandemic and a million people fell into
extreme poverty over the same time
period
joe biden has met with a japanese prime
minister in tokyo as part of his asia
tour as us president he said this
morning that he supports the idea of
japan becoming a permanent member of the
un security council tom standing by for
us in beijing hi tom tell us more about
the meetings that are going ahead
morning care yes i mean this is
president biden's first visit to asia
and it is important given what he said
about trying to focus on the region
obviously events in europe the russian
invasion of ukraine has preoccupied the
white house but this is a sign of its
commitment to the region that's mainly
focused so far on security we've had the
orcas pact between australia the uk and
the us there'll be a meeting of the quad
as well that's the u.s india australia
and japan that's another security
alliance security was at the top of the
agenda today they've just finished this
press conference uh president biden was
asked whether the u.s would intervene
militarily where china to attack taiwan
and he said yes we would intervene now
that seems to be as it stands right now
a difference in the us position which
has long been characterized by what's
called strategic ambiguity not saying
whether or not they would intervene
militarily and perhaps militarily might
mean different things it could be the
supply of weapons so i think we're gonna
probably see some sort of clarification
that from the white house but along with
the carrot uh the stick we've been
talking about there's also the cab the
us wants to compete with china's
economic heft it's announced a new
partnership to do that japan's saying
they'd rather the us actually join the
trans-pacific partnership uh which was
originally set up by the us before
donald trump left it so there is a lot
of questions on the table right now for
this and china really is central to
central to all of it um and i think it
takes a pretty dim view of what's
happening uh yesterday the foreign
minister of china wangy uh talking about
this he said the us's so-called
indo-pacific strategy is doomed to
failure
okay for now thanks tom
anthony albanese has been sworn in as
australia's new prime minister just a
warning these uh next pictures actually
do contain some flash photography here
we go mr albanese's election victory
meant the end of nearly a decade of rule
by the conservative coalition the labour
leader promised a journey of change as
he vowed to tackle climate change rising
living costs and inequality he'll now
head to japan for a summit with
president biden along with the leaders
of japan and also india
seven people have died after a fire on a
boat carrying 134 passengers and crew
off the province of quezon in the
philippines the fire reportedly started
from the engine room was eventually
brought under control with the wreckage
towed to shore
a plane with enough infant formula for
more than half a million baby bottles
has arrived in the us from europe after
one of the biggest shortages in recent
history according to the white house
it's the first of several flights
carrying infant formula from europe to
relieve the nationwide issues
afghanistan's taliban rulers have begun
enforcing an order requiring all female
tv news presenters in the country to
cover their faces while on air
the rule was announced on thursday and
only a handful of programmes complied
but yesterday most presenters were seen
to be covered up
the team at the afghan news channel tolo
news posted a picture on social media of
both their male and female staff wearing
face coverings in an apparent act of
quick look at the weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we'll all see some wet weather in the
coming week as conditions become cooler
and more unsettled largely cloudy start
to the day with showers already over
northern and western parts
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
sports stars including the boxer anthony
joshua and footballer jaden sancho have
reached out to show their support to 11
year old raheem bailey after he was
reportedly bullied and attacked by a
group of children at his school on
tuesday
his mom chantelle bailly said her son
got his finger caught on a fence when
trying to escape the bullies
and it later had to be amputated the
family have received more than 90 000
pounds in donations since setting up a
gofundme page for the treatment and this
is the gofundme page right now just
showing it 91 almost 92
000 pounds for that little man
uh in the guardian it seems the people
of grantham are still divided over a
statue of the former prime minister
margaret thatcher erected in the area it
was even egged within hours of going up
maybe the money
could have been spent elsewhere some
suggest but there we are
we also have some impressive pictures of
australian acrobats in the telegraph
practicing their act in brighton's royal
pavilion gardens
most impressive isn't it i think we've
got one more for you here we go
a lovely picture of sharon stone looking
radiant on the red carpet
at the 75th can film festival looks
amazing
prince william's 40th birthday next
month and the royal mint have decided to
mark the occasion you guessed it by
releasing a five pound coin featuring
his uh portrait there we are giving him
quite a bit of hair as well have you
noticed uh it's the first time the duke
will appear alone on an official uk coin
as you can see number 40 is uh here to
his left
the queen is about to celebrate her
platinum jubilee
something that no other monarch has done
that's 70 years of duty dedication and
service sky news will bring you the
celebrations and pageantry to mark this
historic occasion plus
a very special guest
i'll be joining the sky news team as we
celebrate the very best of britain and
we cannot wait that's the platinum
jubilee on sky news
[Music]
coming up we're going to be speaking to
a global health expert about the spread
of monkey pox with officials expecting a
significant rise in infections this week
[Music]
hello again everybody very good morning
to you you're very welcome to join us on
the breakfast show here on sky news the
prime minister waits for sue gray's
report into lockdown breaking parties in
downing street it's expected by midweek
meantime the uk is expected to announce
more cases of monkey pox this morning
anyone at risk of having caught the
virus is advised to
advise to isolate for 21 days
a review of child protection in england
is calling for a radical reset to avoid
tens of thousands more children being
put into care
growing pressure on the government to
take more action to tackle the rising
cost of living but there's disagreement
among conservative ministers over
whether there should be a windfall tax
on energy companies making huge profits
short time ago the chief secretary to
the treasury simon clark told me they're
certainly not ruling it out
these are extraordinary circumstances we
recognize there are extraordinary
pressures on family finances and the
industry needs to hear the message loud
and clear if investment doesn't go in
we can't rule out
73 of those who voted conservative in
2019 support a windfall tax well i think
the public are absolutely concerned
about the situation that they can see
and you're not there
we're not ruling it out it is a test for
the industry does this does this
investment come forward and if it
doesn't uh frankly reflecting the
seriousness of the situation uh they can
expect the government to have to look at
all our options
tamara is here it sounded like it was
softening to me very much so i think
that's the strongest hint yet we've had
from a minister that a windfall tax a
big u-turn which would give a victory to
labour who've been calling for one maybe
on the card simon clark treasury
minister there saying extraordinary
times and extraordinary pressures on
families now you're seeing more and more
tories coming out and saying maybe we
don't think this is very conservative
but we need to raise money somehow to
help people with energy bills that are
only going to go up and up and up
towards the end of the year perhaps to
as much as 3 000 pounds now simon clark
there was saying look we want the oil
and gas companies to invest and if they
don't invest then we will then impose
this tax what exactly that means what
level of investment he didn't set out
there and we've seen some of the big oil
giants already saying they're going to
shell has said we're going to invest 20
to 25 billion bp 18 billion over the
next 10 years these investment plans are
done quite a long while in advance the
treasury are clearly saying they want
them to speed it up some some companies
have not announced their investment plan
so they all want to put the pressure on
but exactly what threshold they're
looking at has not been made clear now
while the treasury seems to be softening
up the prime minister and others in
cabinet are yet to be convinced that a
windfall tax is the way forward and
there's big questions about what exactly
they would spend the money on whether
you just give it to all households lower
income households use it for some kind
of tax cut all that is tbc but i think
we saw simon clark there clearly leaning
into it a lot more than we have seen
over the past few hours and the thought
on sugree going to great lengths to say
that um she's independent
yes and i think um downing street are
frustrated by um this this row of the
weekend about and who
requested the meeting with us revealing
on friday that there had been a meeting
between the prime minister and sue gray
her team insisting at the prime
minister's request downing street
insisting it was at her request and
there's some emails
to justify that i think simon clark was
trying to provide a bit of context there
that we hadn't had before saying look of
course sue gray and some in the number
10 team have been in contact because
there are welfare issues to do with some
of the junior staff who may be named you
know their careers may be affected by
all this there are issues to work
through which is why we didn't get the
sue grey report the minute the police
investigation concluded because who's
going to be named whether there are
going to be pictures and the impact that
that may have on all the people involved
of course has got to be worked through
but um yes we are eagerly awaiting that
report uh number ten sort of putting
about that they are relaxed about it
they want this all to be over but
clearly some of the details in there
could be really damaging and we will we
understand get photos as well um some in
number 10 saying look we're hopeful
these won't will show that this wasn't
swinging from chandeliers this was you
know possibly people in close contact
but not maybe some of the more lurid
suggestions people have made but clearly
i think they're braced for it to be a
very difficult week we must remember
that a child's swing was broken though
thank you very much tomorrow we'll see
you at the top of the next hour and of
course tomorrow's take at nine o'clock
thank you let's get more now on the
pressure facing the prime minister ahead
of the release of that party report
joined by former justice secretary and
former conservative mp david cook hello
to you mr court thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning your thoughts
first of all uh if i may ask you for um
this meeting that went ahead
between
mrs gray and the prime minister no
matter who instigated it
i suppose first of all i don't imagine
that stu gray is someone who can be
pressured into changing what she was
going to say so i suspect in terms of
the substance it hasn't made that much
difference
i don't know whether that was the
intention behind such a meeting quite
possibly wasn't it may well be other
reasons why a meeting was held
but i think it's unfortunate
i think from the perspective of the
prime minister that there is this row
and it probably wasn't the best idea for
there to be such a meeting because
people will immediately draw conclusions
that this was an attempt to pressure her
i i i don't know whether that is the
case if there was an attempt to pressure
i suspect it wouldn't work but but i i
think it's um perhaps a little bit
sloppy uh but careless to have such a
meeting uh with the risk that this would
be the interpretation that people would
have
um you previously said you'd be
surprised if there was no more fines for
the prime minister how surprised are you
i was surprised um i i think it is
you know i think it surprised a lot of
people uh given that the birthday party
looks like the least serious of of many
of these
uh i think some some of us even had a
little bit of sympathy with the prime
minister on that particular case
uh and and other cases looked more
serious the metropolitan police haven't
explained
as far as i'm aware why they have drawn
that distinction and uh people will
continue to ask questions
about it but i think the most important
thing when it comes to the parties i
mean everybody got very focused on the
fines and the police investigation there
are two other important issues for the
prime minister
first of all was there a culture in
number 10 where the rules were
floundered
and
as the prime minister as the occupant of
10 downing streets
you'd expect the prime minister to take
some responsibility for that culture
secondly
did he tell the truth to parliament
throughout this process
and i think there are clearly
significant questions still to be
answered on those points
so i don't think that uh the issue has
completely gone away
um it probably has strengthened the
prime minister's political position the
fact that he hasn't been fined but
there's those fundamental questions that
we were all asking back in february
before the police got involved
uh continued to exist
except of course he has taken
responsibility he has cleared out quite
a lot of his top team it looks as though
another may be falling on their sword
when the report comes out later on this
week is when we're expecting it middle
of the week um and he also went to
parliament to apologize so don't we all
have to move on now
well not not not really i don't think
this is taking the the level of
responsibility that he he should have
done
and and if he has misled parliament uh
and there are still questions
uh i think to be raised about that then
he he hasn't certainly hasn't taken
responsibility for that so that i think
as i say there remains issues uh on this
but but i i think the reality is is is
that the momentum towards a vote of no
confidence has has dissipated uh and
that looks unlikely to happen for the
time being um so it was good news for
the prime minister last week but as i
say i think there are still some very
difficult questions for him to answer
and i'm not sure that uh you know paying
a fine and changing your staff
is necessarily accepting uh full
responsibility for everything that
happened
government made quite clear if i can
talk about the northern ireland protocol
that it isn't working and needs to be
changed she used to be the justice
secretary of course
that's quite a tight rope isn't it how
do you start to walk that
i think if you want to change the
protocol and and you know there there
are i think perfectly reasonable
arguments to say that not all the checks
are necessary but we can slim some of
those down
but you've got to build a relationship
of trust with the european union and the
impression that the government has given
is that it signed an agreement without
the intention
of being honest about it to the people
of northern ireland
and without the intention of sticking to
that deal
and that their intention was you know
once it was signed that they would come
back and reopen it
and and that i think breeds distrust
the attempts to to try to change this
unilaterally uh is is
i think the view of most lawyers a
breach of international law
and a breach of trust
and i think that makes it harder to get
a constructive deal done
and to address some of the as i say
perfectly reasonable concerns that some
of the checks that exist here aren't
really necessary
in order to protect the european union
single market but but you have got to
have that as i say that relationship of
trust and the government really hasn't
uh done anything to build that trust up
okay good to talk to you mr thanks for
joining us on the program thank you
uk is expected to announce small cases
of monkey pox this morning anyone at
risk of having caught the virus is
advised to isolate for up to 21 days a
little earlier we heard from a
government minister who said he was
cautious but not concerned about the
situation well joining us now is senior
research fellow in global health at the
university of southampton that's dr
michael head hello to doctor thank you
for joining us what is monkey pox
good morning so monkey boxes of virus
has been around for a long long time it
exists predominantly in sub-saharan
africa particularly in places like ghana
and nigeria and also the democratic
republic of congo it's similar to the
smallpox virus we do occasionally see
imported infections here in the uk but i
think the key with this outbreak here
is the extent of human to human
transmission usually it's an infection
you pick up directly from an animal
reservoir which we think is probably
rats
but here there's a lot of community
transmission so that's concerning it is
a particularly nasty virus
but i think it would stress at this
point it's not covered infectious
diseases do behave very differently so
the outbreak is important we get it
under control but we're not likely to
see anything on the scale of what we've
seen with coding 19 this last two years
most cases here in the uk at the moment
are among gay and bisexual men why is
that
so that's presumably where the index
case was the first case covert
monkey pox requires very close contact
to transmit uh this can be via
respiratory aerosols often also via
things like skin to skin contact so the
kind of very notable blisters and rashes
you get as a skin presentation you can
transmit via touching those
so i think the sexual networks that
we're seeing here uh the transmission is
taking place within those sexual
networks so it's important we don't
stigmatize these communities but of
course we do need to raise public health
awareness
and make sure that anybody who's
potentially been exposed does keep an
eye out for signs that they might be
becoming a case
if people are showing monkey problems
monkey pox symptoms what should they do
i think sick medical help will be the
first thing but also i note that uh
public health guidance is saying if you
are uh
high risk of being infected then to
isolate for 21 days so essentially
report to a health facility um and then
the sort of public health advice will
follow but i think for example like
suggesting people isolate for 21 days if
requested to that'll be useful in
helping people helping stop the chains
of transmission so that will bring the
outbreak under control quicker
yeah i'm just reading actually um that
joe biden's talking about this very um
issue while he's in uh the far east and
he's saying that people shouldn't be on
duly concerned and he's pretty relaxed
about a people quarantining for 21 days
as well we do we do have um a vaccine
don't we that we can use if necessary
yes so the smallpox vaccine is also
protective against um monkeybox as well
and even if you're infected if it's
given very early in the infection then
it still provides some use so that's
kind of a weapon in our armory again
there's another difference between
cover 19s that we have these tools we
also have interesting knowledge on how
to stop monkey pox outbreaks so smallpox
vaccine may be used here in the uk i
think other countries have recommended
routinely using it for cases and exposed
contacts as well so that's another thing
that we might see going forward is more
use smallpox vaccine
okay you sounded so you're not unduly
concerned at this stage doctor
i think the threats to the wider german
public are very low so again from that
perspective i'm not concerned it is the
nasty virus if you have been exposed
that is more of a concern uh but to most
people it won't be impacting upon their
daily lives like coping 19 has
okay thank you thanks very much
now a landmark review into the state of
child protection in england says radical
changes
are needed to avoid tens of thousands
more children being put into care the
independent review of children's social
care says the current state of the
system is a human tragedy here's jason
farrell
amber has waived her anonymity to tell
how her life in the care system from the
age of 13 was a journey to isolation and
abuse removed from her family in hull
she was bounced through nine foster
placements then three residential homes
hundreds of miles apart
you just always wonder why you're not
good enough to stay there and
it'll always be in the back of my mind
like why weren't i good enough just to
why didn't they want me why didn't they
want me to stay there
amber's friend millie not her real name
went missing from care 280 times over a
three-year period the pair ran away
together and were both abused by a gang
of men the independent review of
children's social care calls for a
revolution in family help to keep
families together describing the state
of the current child care system as a
human tragedy
i still think if i hadn't gone into care
i wouldn't have seen half of things i've
seen
i wouldn't have gone missing or got off
to random houses of dangerous men
being aware from like a family
area you just like people like see the
vulnerabilities amber's mother who
doesn't want to appear on camera feels
her daughter was safer at home
amber changed massively changed and
and it was so worrying because nobody
had listened nobody would do anything
like and all social services was
bothered about was getting her back to
where she needed to be and that was it
over a two and a half year period amber
went missing 106 times a report shown to
her mother suggested she'd been
regularly abused by men
eventually she was moved into a secure
unit which she says was like a prison
and didn't address her problems
i think at the time they just felt out
of sight out of mind because i was
locked up in a secure unit like they had
no
no i'm not going to tell anyone am i i'm
not going to speak out
parents are powerless because
as far as they're concerned we've lost
our kids so you you just be quiet now
you know you can't say anything
so you feel like the social services
system is essentially pushing her into
the clutches of these of these men yeah
yeah
the top 10 child care providers made 300
million pounds profit last year the
review suggests a windfall tax on them
to help pay for families in crisis to
try to keep them together if the
recommendations are followed the review
team claims in 10 years it would help
keep 30 000 children out of the care
system jason farrell sky news
russia is continuing its offensive in
eastern ukraine it appears to have made
slow moves forward in the dom bus in
recent days where it wants to expand the
territory that moscow backed separatists
have held since 2014.
joining us now is the former chief of
the general staff lord richard dunnett
hello timor thank you for joining us on
the program this morning um the loss of
mario paul
is a big loss isn't it for ukraine
well it is but i think as all of us who
have been following that story over the
last few weeks and months now realize
that mario paul was always going to fall
at some point
i think the significance of it from the
ukrainian's point of view was just how
long the fighters within the
steel works managed to hold out and hold
on
because that dragged in sucked in quite
large numbers of russian troops who
otherwise might have been deployed
elsewhere but i think mario paul we had
to accept was always going to fall which
now means that uh that objective that
the russians wanted to achieve of a land
link from crimea through mario paul into
the donbass into russia proper has now
been
achieved
so
we've heard also from uh president
zielinski he has um been uh speaking at
nightly address of course that he does
uh with the people of ukraine he says
the situation in the donbass is really
hard
how do you expect the situation to
develop from here lord
well this is now the crux of the fight
vladimir putin hasn't achieved very much
part of what i've just described about
that land corridor he hasn't achieved
very much in this war so far and he
feels obviously very strongly he's got
to achieve something and that something
is
in his view the complete control of the
donbass region the donetsk and luhans
provinces
elsewhere they've done really poorly
but
the battle forever several donets is
intensifying at the present moment i
think the russians according to reports
are making some small gains but frankly
small gains isn't going to win uh this
campaign for them and again we have to
remember that this is the region that's
been fought over since 2014 2015 and the
ukrainians by and large are still
retaining the very well prepared
defensive positions that they've
occupied for the last six seven eight
years
and with ukrainians standing on the
defense it's the russians who have to
throw their combat power against
well-prepared ukrainian positions and
that's largely explains why the russians
are taking so many casualties
but the blockade of odessa is going to
be
a huge problem not just for ukraine and
their exports but also the grain that
would normally be traveling around the
world we're hearing from dominic waghorn
a little early this hour i'm sure you
heard it my lord saying that people can
starve as a result of that blockade
well you're absolutely right this is one
of those major issues
it doesn't just affect ukraine and
ukrainian people
it affects
give me affects all of us uh worldwide
because if the world can't access
that huge uh amount of ukrainian grain
which normally comes out into the black
sea through ports previously like mario
pole and odessa then we're all going to
suffer a huge shortage and of course
those who've been following this story
closely we'll know that much of the
much of the grain that goes into the
world food food programme to help
poorer countries a lot of that comes
from ukraine and indeed russia and that
just isn't going to be on the world
market but the situation around odessa
from a military point of view is a very
interesting one to watch uh the
ukrainians will be desperate are
desperate to hold on to odessa but they
can't use it as a port at the present
moment for defensive reasons they've
heavily mined it they've very heavily
defended the city and are determined to
prevent the russians capturing odessa
and pushing up through the transnistra
in in moldova so while all that's going
on i'm afraid the grain is not going to
flow into the black sea and it's just
worth
mentioning as a footnote the russian
commander of the black sea fleet has
himself been fired as indeed has the
commander of first guard's tank army
whose troops failed so uh abysmally
around the northeast city of kharkiv
things actually are not going very well
for the russians but there are
implications for all of us not least
this issue of the flow of grain or not
flow of grain
okay um just before i let you go um we
are talking about what's happening in
odessa of course and mario paul meantime
the the human tragedy for those still uh
left in ukraine continues to mount
well that's absolutely right um
millions of people displaced within
ukraine millions of people now having
left ukraine
the response from the world has been
have been fantastic
but we've got to go on supporting
ukraine with support for her people and
with weapons and ammunition for her
armed forces but i think the other thing
kate that's just worth just focusing on
is the war of words that's developing uh
zielinski is quite rightly saying he's
not going to
be prepared to give up um an inch of of
ukrainian soil
he really has to say that particularly
because his soldiers fighting in donbass
must feel that they're fighting for a
worthwhile cause if there's any hint of
the ukrainians being prepared to accept
the reality of the situation and give up
some of that territory in donbass than
the will to fight from their soldiers
will be significantly drained down
okay thank you my lord for joining us on
the program as always much appreciated
thanks kate i just want to bring you the
latest that we're hearing um on the
pitch invasion um after the game in
manchester manchester city yesterday the
final game of the season of course when
they uh
at the top of the league well we're
hearing that two fans have been
um arrested and charged philip maxwell
who is 28.
he's been charged with throwing a
missile a firework onto the pitch and
paul colbridge who is oh i can't work
that out he was born in 84. um he has
been charged with going on to the pitch
and will appear at manchester and
salford magistrates court uh in a couple
of weeks time stay tuned for more here
on sky
[Music]